bonjour et bienvenue sur le diagonal
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs alors aujourd'hui au programme
l'actualité de canal web dépôt de bilan
aux pressions judiciaires et compagnie
également nous aurons les commentaires
sur le championnat du monde sur internet
évidemment c des qualifications sur
internet c'est très très compliqué
triche ou pas tricher bien nous en
saurons plus également etienne bacrot
qui fait un match contre émile sud offs
qui le champion d'europe en titre et qui
est en train de mener le match alors
nous avons évidemment pour présenter
cette émission notre présentateur
vedette stéphane laborde bonjour quand
même vous jouerez loi alors donc
actualité chargée on va y revenir avec
pour ça on invitait que tu va nous
présenter un nouveau de nouveau mais les
livres n'y a pas longtemps il vient tout
le temps ils viennent tout le temps donc
c'est jean-luc chavanon invité permanent
maître international et donc et ancien m
intégrant mettre maintenant et non mais
ça c'est normal il a été maître pendant
très longtemps maintenant et les grands
maîtres et donc il est de retour sur
diagonale pour avec maintenant son
nouveau statut de grand maître qui a eu
un peu de mal à digérer et aux
championnats de france mais ça va
revenir
donc elle en jean luc tu seras en phase
de digestion du titre devant m oui donc
je suis en phase de digestion g j'ai
souffert du syndrome donc du titre de
grand maître international c'est à dire
qu'ils vont dès qu'on obtient ce titre
en général c'est la gamelle donc bon
maintenant je vais ont fait le lien plus
sérieusement dans dans la compétition on
verra en fin d'émission toujours un
tournoi à menton
très bientôt donc là on espère te revoir
en pleine forme alors aujourd'hui nous
allons parler d'eux canal web pour en
savoir plus la semaine dernière nous
recevions jacques rosselin qui nous
disait dépôt de bilan effectivement donc
stéphane que s'est il passé
il y a eu une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle oui enfin disons que on s'y
attendait quand même un peu c'est à dire
que le tribunal de commerce a décidé
qu'elle pouvait continuer son activité
donc ça me tire les actionnaires
historiques de canal web ont décidé de
remettre au pot or maintenant de
remettre un petit coup effectivement
donc de continuer l'activité simplement
pour que ça soit validée par le trident
commerce il faut que ça soit une
activité qui soit financièrement
équilibrée que ça n'augmente pas le
passif est donc pour ça il faut se
concentrer sur les activités de canal
web qui rapporte de l'argent aujourd'hui
et les seules activités qui rapportent
de l'argent sont le 'b to b' c'est à
dire le service aux entreprises
il faut le rappeler diagonale ne gagne
pas d'argent a plutôt tendance à en
perdre le gagnent pas d'argent parce
qu'on n'a rien fait pour mettre en place
des abonnements ou mettre en place un
système qui permettrait d'en gagner
simplement n'a pas eu le temps de le
faire parce que c'était pas prévu de le
faire aussi tôt c'est peut-être dommage
mais c'est comme ça donc il est très
probable n'est pas sûr sur absolument
encore que les gones s'arrête c'est pas
encore sûr puisqu'il possible que
quelques programmes continuent donc de
son plaisir vous en saurez plus très
prochainement on vous tiendra au courant
soit par la newsletter soient en direct
de vive voix
vous en saurez plus sur l'avenir de
diagonale en maintenant le grand débat
de cette semaine c'est donc le
championnat du monde fis des il y avait
qualifié par le classement elo il ya des
qualifiés par zone et il y a huit places
pour les joueurs qui se qualifieraient
sur internet
alors ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que les joueurs sont devant
leur ordinateur on leur donne un
appariement leur donne un horaire de jeu
et là ils sont libres de jouer
maintenant
personne n'est là pour vérifier que le
joueur joue tout seul il peut donc être
accompagnés d'autres joueurs de grand
maître expérimenté de grandes et très
fort et évidemment d'ordinateurs donc
tout ça pose un problème évidemment
moral on voit des joueurs non classés
qui joue un niveau de grand maître
international
ça paraît tout à fait mouche alors jean
luc ton analyse en tant que joueur
professionnel de ce système de
qualification sur internet les avantages
les inconvénients
mais les avantages c'est que quelque
part on peut dire que cela démocratise
un petit peu le jeu d'échecs cela permet
un amateur donc de se qualifier aux
championnats du monde un joueur qui est
nettement moins fort que les autres
joueurs
bon donc ça c'est l' avantage ce qui
fait que tout le monde a envie de
participer à cette compétition
l'inconvénient c'est que finalement
c'est celui qui est quand même le mieux
équipé et kiala la plus grosse puissance
de machines qui qui qui va probablement
se qualifier donc alan est ce qu'on peut
dire que tous les joueurs jouent avec
des machines un intérêt important
peut-on jouer sans ordinateur à côté
j'imagine mal donc actuellement donc vu
le classement qu'obtiennent certaines
machines qui aux alentours de 2650
j'imagine mal un joueur même enfin un
joueur de ma force
essayer de jouer ce genre de compétition
sans machine d'ailleurs moi c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de ne
pas y participer
on va rappeler quand même jean-luc que
les machines sont interdites alors elles
sont interdites mais en même temps on
peut pas contrôler j'avais une
aberration de règlement stéphane non
mais bon du moment qu'on peut pas
contrôler on peut pas appliquer un
règlement ça c'est clair
comme s'il y avait un contrôle anti
doping non mais quand ya une loi il ya
une police s'il ya pas de police il ya
pas de droit n'a pas de contrôle
ce n'est pas la peine de faire une loi
c'est ça sert à rien en plus on a du mal
à comprendre comment vérifier puisque si
si un joueur utilise deux ordinateurs
une machine pour travailler pour
analyser la position et notre machine
pour pour transmettre les coûts donc sur
le serveur internet
donc on imagine
comment faire un contrôle il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas de solution c'est un
règlement il y à une solution il ya une
solution qui existe on va quand même
l'un appelé la fille d il ya pensé on
peut porter réclamation en disant voilà
mon adversaire a joué tous les coups de
l'ordinateur vérifiez vous prenez les
temps de réflexion vous regardez ce que
donne l'ordinateur après tel temps de
réflexion et vous voyez il a joué
systématiquement le coup l'ordinateur
initiale de deviner quel programme
il faut deviner quel programme puisqu'il
chante pas tous les mêmes coûts en plus
pour porter réclamation il faut quand
même payer 200 dollars
ouais donc tout le monde a envie de
porter réclamation c'est évident donc
voilà donc finalement en pratique il n'y
aura jamais de contrôle et donc tout le
monde peut dire que ça va mieux il ya
quand même eu contre exemple kasparov
avait organisé grand prix sur internet
qui a eu l'an dernier qui avait perdu
d'ailleurs perdu en finale contre your
une piquette
mais dans cette compétition là il y
avait un arbitre
chez chaque joueur oui tout à fait mais
là c'était limité à 16 joueurs ce grand
prix kasparov donc on pouvait envoyer
des arbitres à ces endroits différents
la commune à 64 joueurs on peut pas
envoyer d'arbitrage 64 tournois
différents points où il réussit pas
c'est pas les mêmes joueurs sont pas les
mêmes joueurs donc voilà donc alors bon
exemple en pratique avant de commenter
etienne bacrot contre site off ce qui
est bien une partie d'olic et touzanne
le joug sympathique joueur toulousain
maintenant montpelliérains toujours très
sympathique et olivier touzanne qui
scorent un maximum puisqu'il est
actuellement deuxième de la compétition
avec trois points et demi sur 4 en ayant
battu des très fortes hausses oui
olivier tout jeune qui est maître
international qui
il ya donc un résultat assez fantastique
par rapport à son à son rang dans la
hiérarchie internationale et qui est en
passe de se qualifier donc pour une
compétition pour laquelle je pense que
il n'aurait pas forcément sa place en
suivant le conduire le cycle classique
c'est-à-dire le donna le championnat
d'europe
tout simplement je pense que je peux à
d'europe il y à il ya beaucoup trop de
grands maîtres de premier plan et c'est
très très difficile alors à noter quand
même on va un peu faire le tour des
joueurs qui participent à cette
compétition on voit deux par exemple
sergei ship of qui est un virus
extrêmement fort wauquiez vix le joueur
polonais laurent frayssinet christian
bauer igor nataf tout une tout un tas de
remettre français et bien entendu des
inconnus les illustres inconnus que
personne ne connaît qu'on n'a jamais
vues qui sont non classés des fois et
qui eux aussi font partie de la tête du
classement il faut aussi voir la
performance exceptionnelle de certains
sartoux gates ans gaëtan sartoux
militants sartoux qui lui n'est pas
maître international je crois est qui et
qui fait une performance incroyable
vraiment incroyable des parties
fantastique donc on peut supposer
beaucoup de choses assez long terme et
devrait signer mais de tous dont l'un
d'entre eux en face et de toute façon je
crois que c'est surtout la fidh et qui à
remettre
comment dire le le règlement la fidh et
qu'il remette en question finalement
puisque tout le monde semble utiliser
des ordinateurs pourquoi l'interdire
finalement on va dire que ce championnat
sera un championnat de dhe curie ce sera
d échec annoncé
les échecs avancées avec des grosses
écuries donc une éclipse toute une team
qui qui soutient le joueur donc qui
donne son nom au finalement il donne son
nom à une sorte de marque
donc on peut même supposer que la valeur
serait là mais ne jouerait pas par
exemple on peut dire que si ça se trouve
sous l'ipa n'a pas joué une seule partie
c'est son team qui a joué à sa place
exacte le joueur a même pas besoin
d'être présent il peut simplement
encaissé la place elle en finale et
ensuite on envisager tout un tas de
possibilités
bon on va tout de suite passé au niveau
de jeu qui est totalement incroyable
vraiment des parties d'une qualité
remarquable c'est du semi rapides c'est
surprenant
olivier douzaine contre tête brand alors
tout de suite la partie d'une politique
use and i'll et blanc ce qui se fait de
grandes têtes blondes sont américains
que jean-luc connaît sans doute têtes
blondes donc c'est un grand spécialiste
du jeu du jeu sur internet c'est un
joueur amateur qui doit avoir un niveau
donc on est un niveau modeste mais qui
qui a su s'équiper et qui doit avoir
quand même des connaissances du jeu
correct qui a suisse équipe et donc qui
a préparé donc sont comment dire son
matériel informatique pour pour ce
championnat du monde et ses résultats
c'est une supputation évidemment on n'a
pas de preuves on n'a pas de preuve et
vont pas le prouver mais bon donc c'est
un joueur finalement donc actuellement
l'intérêt finalement c'est une sorte de
guerre stratégique aux championnats du
monde c'est à dire utilisez donc des des
armes technologiques alors qu'on peut
supposer que lier tous donnent aussi
évidemment utiliser un ordinateur
exactement donc maintenant on utilise
des armes technologiques pour vaincre
son adversaire sur sur l'échiquier ça
devient ça devient des limites de la
science fiction exactement vient alors
la partie des quatre cavaliers m6 c'est
qu'apocalypse 3g 6 g iii alors j'ai
trois c1
cela mène plutôt des positions fermes et
donc un peu anti ordinateur peut-être
fou g7 fou g2 petit rock petit rock des
six c4 donc là on est dans la position
de base de l'as cannes manager 3 pour en
savoir plus vous pouvez aller dans
diagonale la leçon je veux la défense
estrade yens contre j'ai 3 vous aurez
tout un tas d analyse sur cette position
ou g3 qui est une des armes les plus
redoutables contre les stars viennent
avec la baïonnette
oui et d'ailleurs je crois que garry
kasparov lui-même la refuse
en général ils préfèrent jouer des 5 et
est transposée dans une grotte failli ne
pas jouer avec des six jouée ces six des
5 avec une position équilibrée il a fait
beaucoup de nuls contre anatoli karpov
en tout cas les noirs sont en défense il
avait d'ailleurs joué une partie
remarquable contre contre vladislav
quatre chefs à la coupe du monde donc où
il avait fait ils avaient fait match nul
n'avait pas gagné avec les noirs mais
c'était une partie d'une combativité
incroyable cavale et b17 kbc 3e 5
donc là c'est une réaction normale des
noirs c'est une variante tout à fait
classique eux quatre ces six là c'est la
théorie tous à jean-luc ici les blancs
au centre ne peut pas bouger ce pion
puisque s'ils prennent ça ségalis tout
de suite après des problèmes s'ils
avancent
eh bien ça donne trop de cases on peut
jouer avec d'un v6 qui a laissé cinq des
plans comme ça il n'y a pas de problème
pour les noirs donc ici les blancs ne
bouge pas au centre c'est le principe
et ils essayent de provoquer les noirs à
prendre en d4 fait ils veulent que les
noirs prennent en d4 pour reprendre les
cavaliers et ensuite attaqué pions des
six le l'idée positionnelle de cette
ouverture c'est ça donc ici on joue un
petit coup on joue à trois l'idée c'est
le développement naturel du foot sur la
case de 300 craindre qu'à velizy 430 kg
cas tout à fait stéphane puisque le pion
contrôle
donc ça c'est l'idée ici si les noirs
jouent normal eh bien on sait pas trop
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
parce qu'ils ont envie de sortir leurs
pièces mais le fusil de type n'a pas
beaucoup c'est vite a pas beaucoup de
casse donc c'est difficile de se
développer sans prendre là puisqu'on
sait pas quoi faire de notre cavalier 17
donc une des variantes qui existent ses
pions prend des quatre et qui essaient 5
/ coller blanc montage fait ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire la colonne des semi
ouverte sur qui on des six et si les
verts ne prennent part des cartes très
bien on ne sait pas trop ce qu'ils vont
faire
il ya une alternative c'est le coût d'un
v6 la variante hautement théorique
puisque la sueur fouet trois iliad prend
b2 donc évidemment et la menace ses
pions prend des 4 et cavani 34 n'ont pas
bougé ces êtres qui se réveille à une
scène de la reine sur lequel donc ça
d'un v6 et un coup reconnu par la
théorie comme étant assez fort et
haineux contre contre eux pointent en
fait normal on joue tout re 1 ça c'est
la grande ligne toi hein mais il ya
également la position mis au point par
alexei shirov pour la première fois
contre garry kasparov la partie de
référence c'est le coup c'est 5
oui donc sa chance je précise un petit
peu puisque je connais très bien ce
genre de position que que ces cinq donc
est actuellement donc la ligne ce n'est
peut-être pas la grande ligne mais c'est
la ligne qui est joué par les joueurs
tops mondiaux donc depuis cette fameuse
partie d'alexei shirov et je crois même
que youssou peuvent aussi à jouer ça
donc depuis ces parties là où on a vu
que les blancs obtenez vraiment des
chances d'attac incroyable les blancs se
sont mis à jouer cette ligne est
récemment donc il ya le l'ancien
champion du monde qualif man qui avait
gagné une très très belle partie avec
avec cette ligne donc auquel beaucoup de
parties de référence 1 les parts de
référence évidemment c'est ce qui
détermine la théorie moderne
la théorie c'est l'ensemble des
positions existantes donc maintenant
c'est 5 et le coup statistiquement le
plus joué le plus représentatif de
l'évolution de la théorie et chicken
dans cette position et donc après ses
cinq ya une suite force et jean-luc mais
là on est obligé de prendre du plomb des
hans et 5
oui puisque la dame est attaqué donc le
pion des six aussi des procès 5,6 en
province incluant trois de cinq noms
matin les noirs africains huit cavaliers
hui le seul coup 8
voilà donc ces cinq et qui est un
sacrifice de pions alors pour l'instant
c'est toujours l'égalité matériel mais
tu as un qui est perdu mais le pion aux
5es perdu donc dans cette position a
alors que je ferai faire transmis par
exemple jean luc pour défendre le pion
mais c'est pas très intéressant parce
que les normes j'aurais simplement qui a
laissé cette équipe vit aussi une
variante dans ce style par exemple ou
peut-être dame prend b2 peut-être même
prouvé docile en tout cas dans cette
position les blancs ont une ressource
incroyable donc c'est le coup tout
simple 2 5 6 tout simple on sait pas
vraiment le mot l'idée de secours donc 6
les noirs sont obligés de prendre
puisque la menace c'est non seulement
option tranquille mali mais aussi pions
pouces ramassant la tour donc il faut
prendre
voilà et maintenant donc là il ya
vraiment eu un sacrifice de pions mais
quelles en sont les compensations
balleux je crois que le mot qui pourrait
qualifier donc les compensations
seraient seraient des structures et on
pourrait dire que les noirs dans sa
position sont déstructurées c'est à dire
que leur structure depuis on a les
droits par exemple avec h 7 g 6 ie6 est
plus fragile que s'ils font que lorsque
le plan était sur la case eps est tout à
fait impartial quatre rencontres trois
ont fait de ce côté là donc là
effectivement les blancs sont en train
de monter ce qu'on appelle une attaque
contre le roi 1
il faut bien il faut bien le dire le
plan d'attaqué eh bien il est
magnifiquement illustré par cette partie
et c'est une très bonne stratégie de la
part d'olivier touzanne qui s'il
considère que son adversaire ne se joue
pas très bien aux échecs mais en
revanche dispose d'un ordinateur
puissant on sait que le point faible des
ordinateurs et bien c'est quand ils sont
attaqués en le roi est attaquée a
précisé m on peut déjà dire que têtes
blondes dans cette position a fait un
mauvais choix d'ouverture avec une
machine on peut déjà trouver des
conclusions stratégique donc dans cet
emploi donc de l'ordinateur pour pour la
victoire
maintenant reste au conditionnel
stéphane parce qu'on n'est pas sûr à
100% qu'il joue avec machine mais c'est
probable oui c'est hautement power
kg cinq attaques le pion aux dons il y
avait 10 g 5 c'est la manoeuvre quasi
classique dans ce type de position
donc on attaque tout de suite le pion le
plus faible le maillon faible le pion
aux six exactement d'autant plus qu'on
laisse ensuite le pion f avancé
puisqu'il n'est plus bloquée par qui va
directement le nord peuvent pas bloquer
avec 6 e 5 au 6 e 5 à lens stéphane saf
a l'air très bon puisque ça affaiblit
l'état blanche mais je pense qu'on peut
jouer tout simplement cavalier e 6 oui
on peut aller prendre le fou g7 c'est
une possibilité
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres bactéries
aussi ses bons jours et qui a oublié aux
six attaques la tour en attaque
le fou également au passage des petites
mosaïques cavaliers à capter et l'option
c5 donc ici après un coup comme tour m6
par exemple envers andré angers7
on peut aussi jouer cavalier oui on peut
prendre on prend g7 qui avait des
projets 7 et la faune g5 par exemple
avec une position compliquée mais on va
jouer sans doute avec f4 enfin c'est
yann initiative initiative
à noter que c'est pas évident qu'ils
avaient aussi soigné parce que les cases
blanches sont affaiblis peut-être un
coup comme dames 2 peut aussi profiter
de l'affaiblissement des classes blanche
pourront jouer dame ces quatre échecs ce
genre de choix juste d'être plutôt un
bon coup avec la menace aussi de
développement semblent à l'étroit way
down est sans doute préférable ici je
sens que c'est possible
j'en ai de toute façon le 5 est possible
mais c'est un coup quand même un
séducteur kg 5 km à 10 1 5
donc un value 5 et le coût normal donc
normal puisqu'on veut revenir en 27 avec
le niveau rien n'est fait pour échanger
ce cavalier dangereux angers ça et ça
protège le pian et si c'est le foot
c'est 8 défend le pion aux six oui hein
donc tous à cette importante c'est
encore la théorie f4 cavaliers sa qualif
sept cavaliers prime cette épreuve set
et l'a donc dans la partie lointain dans
la partie dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
la partie de qualif man qui la jouait je
crois contre oui contre le numéro un
mexicain gilberto hernandez oui j'irai
des sept partis d'ailleurs récemment
plus que gilberto à hernandez était
l'invité donc on a des bruits du tournoi
d'evry donc
dans cette partie le joueur mexicain
avait repris de la tour directement en
aide cette et cet effet et s'était
retrouvé avec un front ferme et après le
coup eux 4 5 le 4 5 donc le fou et
angers 7 ans fermes et le plan des
blancs maintenance et qui avait lieu le
4 h 4 h 5 on enverra une illustration
dans la partie d'une illustration dans
une position similaire mais ici le fou
g7 se retrouver enfermé donc au lieu de
reprendre la tête on peut asséner ce
qu'on appelle un échec intermedia fou
des quatre échecs quatre échecs le fouet
pas prenable évidemment il défendu
rouage de très logique et maintenant
pour prendre ce qui fait que le fou est
beaucoup plus actif ici qu'il ne l'était
en g7 exactement d'autant plus que les
blancs sont quand même obligé de jouer
au 5 août et intérêt à prendre ce
qu'elle a laissé trois finalement alors
pour lequel ces trois défaites c'est
extrêmement responsable
oui comment responsable parce que quand
on a pris ce cavalier bonne foi et
esclaves alliés va être très actif aussi
puisqu'il va sauter sur la case de 4
visant les cases faible des 6 7 6
éventuellement le g5 donc on va montrer
l'énorme problème de france 3 stéphane
sais quelle pression prend c'est pas les
cases noires qui sont faites ça c'est un
problème sur le long terme
salon appelé de fou pour défendre le 4
mars et la colonne des qui maintenant
est ouverte et donc les blancs peuvent y
accéder facilement
donc comment je vous tombent déjà dans
cette position pas facile difficile de
trouver ne serait-ce qu'un seul coup
puisque tours 17 n'est pas du tout
constructif autour de sa liste qui
attaquent la dame mais ça n'a aucun sens
pêche le foot mgk tout dames 2 madame g4
à la foire d'alger qui est à la fordham
de a l'air très bien également à venir
fouet trois tours il ya un joueur très
très belle position pour les blancs qui
me levais leurs pions - n'ont absolument
pas à s'inquiéter
dans cette situation on voit que les
pièces noires sont englués l'a nettement
à gauche de l'échiquier la torah 8 et le
fou ces huit sont vraiment fous très
très mal placée
je vous prends ces trois ce n'est pas un
coup qu'on pourrait recommander après
1,5 en revanche kbc 7 est un coup très
logique
on veut revenir sur la caisse des 5
voilà peut pas faire plus logique que ça
les noirs ont des cases au centre faut
les exploiter on a déjà bien fourni cap
maintenant on va mettre un cavalier en
d5
maintenant que se passe-t-il cavaliers
au calme mais voilà ce qu ils deviennent
très fort ou viande et 6 tout de suite
parce qu'il semble atteint 11,5 du rayon
de ce cavalier il et il est très fort
cavani des cinq contrôles et la casaque
si c'était quand même la case la plus
importante est maintenant plan de jeu
comment est ce que les blancs font pour
améliorer leurs positions
ça a pas l'air si facile que ça parce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure c'est qu'il
faut remarquer c'est qu'effectivement
les rois les noirs en leur roi un petit
peu en l'air oui puisque les pions sont
peu disloqué et les blancs ont capturé
entre 3 de ce côté donc a priori c'est
quand même de ce côté qu'il faut agir il
faut de toute façon attaqué droit mais
maintenant comment faire puisqu'on ne
peut plus attaquées avec les pièces ça a
l'air clair il faut aussi de casser la
structure l'aller fois aussi de casser
les structures d'appui en veut donc
faire un plan de pions fort bien d'un
plan d'un bélier
après le mobilier un point de lyon qui
évidemment n'est jamais pratiquement
envisagée par l'ordinateur ce genre de
coups l'ordinateur faudrait plutôt des
coups comme qui est des six qui ne
servent à rien puisque l'ordinateur ne
sait pas faire un plan de jeu à
proprement parler ou en tout cas il a du
mal donc le bon coup trouvé par olivier
touzanne h quatre ans très fort et donc
à chaque attaque ou un coup très très
fort un coup très logique
ce qui est quand même usant de cette
position c'est de voir que les blancs
n'ont pas développé leur tour et leur
fouet
quand même ils attaquent quand même
alors bon c'est pas très conventionnel
c'est pas très classique c'est vrai mais
il se trouve que
il est quand même difficile de
d'attaquer ce roi en h2 oui laurent
blanc est extrêmement bien tranquille
alors que le pion b2 et défendu aussi de
manière indirecte
voyez sur four b2 il ya tour b1 le full
serait cloué voyez un encadré sur la
dame le foot d'ailleurs ce qui fait que
on peut se permettre donc de pousser et
c'est quand même des développements les
plus utiles aux autres positions saisir
que h 4 h 5
c'est assez fort parce qu'une fois qu'on
a joué à cinq dont jude mg 4 la dame
albaz en attaque l'option g6 en force
donc ça c'est plutôt plutôt une menace
assez directe d'amd vite jouée par ted
branch witt ce sont certains ne fait
plus rien en décembe 6 c'est juste à les
bouger par le pion csn notamment 16e peu
pression sur youtube et 2 mais bon h5
quand même très logique toujours l'idée
dame gcard puisqu'on voit que la dame en
débitant fait est bien elle ne peut pas
venir d'une part les cas son contrôle et
donc pas de problème tous rêvent cinq
attaques du pion en fait ce coup
cherchent à provoquer les blancs à
prendre et noir veulent que les blancs
prennent comme ça après après la reprise
est bien il espère pouvoir utiliser la
colonne h les noirs évidemment wave 3
donc ça s'est extrêmement bien joué
la part d'olivier toussaint faudra donc
faux f3 tout simplement pour défendre ce
pion h
préparez libérer donc la case g2 pour le
roi oui et après on pourra placer la
tour sur la colonne h et continuelle
attaque du roi noir en j'évite donc là
on voit véritablement chez les blancs ce
qu'on peut appeler un plan d'attaqué on
voit un plan d'attaqué une position donc
si on prend un petit peu donc les
principes donc de certains pédagogues
une position du roi blanc en g2 qui sera
quand même quelque part plus sûr que la
position du roi noir adverse
oui on regarde un petit peu et ce qui
leur permet finalement donc d'ouvrir la
position et et de continuer l'initiative
on voit que le tout problème des noirs
c'est évidemment que ce qui a validé
cinq est indispensable donc il peut pas
servir à l'attack puisqu'ils contrôlent
la casaque 6 donc si on veut tenter
quelque chose avec ce cavalier c'est pas
possible aura toujours quelques 6 qui
sera trop fort le fou des quatre îles a
pas de gaz
la tour f 5 y avait bien placé il faut
absolument ramener la tour arbitres pour
ça on voit pas trop plan fou 17
c'est malheureusement quasi impossible à
cause aucun des six qui est tombée cette
pour un peu alternatif mais qui
affaiblirait la structure d'options de
l'autre côté également donc sa tête ben
n'a absolument pas voulu permettre ça
d'ailleurs je voulais dire que le joueur
mexicain n'avait peut-être pas eu tort
quand il avait décidé de garder son four
g7 où il est au co existent puisque les
deux coups sont c'est le carrefour donc
de théorique de la position et avec un
fond j'ai c'est peut-être que le roi est
plus en sécurité c'est une
une éventualité peut-être brandissent y
joue un coup capitule at war touré fuite
c'est un retour de la tour
c'est pas très joli c'est pas très joli
mais il ne sait plus quoi faire
il n'arrive pas à trouver lui de plans
de défense sociale ville un plan
d'attaqué ça c'est typiquement un coup
qui a l'air d'un coup d'ordinateurs oui
puisque ça s'intègre pas dans assassin's
creed pas vraiment dans un plan mais on
aurait plutôt envie de jouer au pire
effectivement fou bessette ce d7000 même
donné le ton mais c'est de voir jouer
peut-être à scène comme si on jouait
d'activer la tour pas raciste b6
peut-être oui même si c'est pas ça pas
l'air top dance n ont donc joué à cinq
des cinq étoiles 7 c'est un plan qui
côtoie régulièrement moyens aussi bon
ici tout est fluide c'est pas un plan
scénique sauf un plan ouais alors que
les bleus ils ont un plan et de tours h
1 d'abord il ya peut-être des finesses
de toute façon le prochain coup savez 3g
de avec colonne h la fameuse colonne h
rocher cet toujours pas de plan chez les
noirs toujours pas de plan à noter que
c'est difficile d'en proposer un mais en
tout cas il était sans doute préférable
de chercher vraiment un truc pour
activer cette tour habite on pense
vraiment à fouday cette fuite l'homme à
5 baies san keller bons à cinq dessins
qui avait 105 c'est vrai que ça aurait
été beaucoup plus utile d'être le roi
reste elle a pas l'air terrible et ça
leur salaire solide pour les noirs
finalement qu'eric g5
ouais donc là petit changement dans le
plan enfin disons amélioration du plan c
un orgueil d' comme on dit on veut
mettre le feu aux quatre l'adamant g4
aileron g2 parce qu'on n'a pas peur sur
ce genre de coup à une
contre attaque qui serait h6 celui de g5
alors ashes dans cette position stéphane
on va le regarder tout de suite
ouais là l'intérêt 106 donc là en toute
logique on joue qu'à vidéo 4 n'est pas
vraiment de sa crise de pièces qui se
profile donc avis aux cartes et là il va
naturellement g5 et g5 donc songer sens
que je pense qu'on peut avec l'idée que
commence à attaquer 4 donc qui devient
faible et si on prend oui bah gsm quand
j'ai cinq déserté le pion aux scènes qui
sautent faucon 25
on prend en justice maintenant héros à
schwyz voilà ça sans visage ça sans
visage c'est compliqué mais le roi noir
et quand même pas vraiment sécurité
encore un nom le roi est alors en aurait
pas de sécurité
mais les noirs ont pas résolu leurs
problèmes de développement met donc ça à
boucher la colonne h la colonne h les
bouchers et qu'il prend ses 5 stéphane
bouquet procès si vous mangez sain
cosigné vous les 5 et pas mal de la
santé violence des points très vite
c'est jouable
oui de toute façon la position après kg
5 et est catastrophique on doute quand
même que je suis ce geste d'impuissance
une solution au problème des mois ça a
pas l'air évident du tout les blancs une
très belle position de la taxe est il
faut voir et l'ordinateur donc si ted
branch joue bien avec un ordinateur est
bien ne propose jamais de coupe
constructif en défense c'est là
qu'olivier touzanne a plutôt bien
calculé son kung fu 17 c'est le vin
maintenant il ya plus de vue qui est des
six pieds premier set
bon je vous fous 17 c'est normal fouet
quatre attaques continuent c'est grosse
attaque pour gaza peut menacer des
cavaliers prend h7 peut-être aurait pas
encore simplement rage et 2 je crois que
moi j'ai donné ensuite tu reprends g6 et
où rached ya pas besoin de se presser
tourache huit dames g4 ça monte ça monte
grave là la menace directe qui épongent
cette menace extrêmement fort puisque
après avec la dame 4 et le fou la dame
j'ai capté le folk at elle changé si ce
qui tombe avec un réseau de maths
donc tout ça ça se passe sur quatre
blanche donc jean luc les noirs doivent
défendre des quatre manches il est noir
doivent absolument défendre le pion g6
et en même temps le pion le 6 qui en
prise par le cavalier la dame donc le
coût qui défend les deux pions c'est le
ku'damm huit dames vite puisque
effectivement comme tu l'as dit aussi
c'est également aux prises non des mots
vides c'est normal et là un petit coup
assez brillant
lier tout jeune il ne joue pas en manger
de tout de suite il aurait pu faire
ils ne jouent pas ils jouent food et 2,1
coûts de développement donc ça c'est
vraiment pour prouver aux noirs qui
n'ont pas de défense n'ont pas de coût
ils peuvent plus rien faire comme ils
sont complètement muselé c'est un très
joli coup sûr fou prend b2 j'ai envie
qu'il y encore tour bientôt bien
surprendre mais c est hélas hélas assez
mortes et abala ça rajoute encore une
tour à l'attack un statut ça c'est
l'antenne donc l'option b douai pas
vraiment prise à quoi ça sert fou des
deux est bien à ramener la tour quand
elle voudra c'est à dire c'est une c on
augmente notre potentiel d'attentât
dames 7 les noirs savent plus quoi faire
ils savent que wilson david suite damas
est alors là il faut calculer la banque
qui est proche est oui tiacoh
intéressante donc ce roi prend sur
l'emprunt g6 matt matt d'un projet 6 et
surtout reprendre renforcé d'un projet 6
un projet si c'est la torah suite j'ai
toujours acheté défendre la tourache est
défendue par la démo 7c lapointe et si
c'est pas si facile de continuer la tacc
il ya sans doute des solutions sont
toutes là notre tour va revenir en
défense en g8
oui exactement en fait on ouvre les
lignes contre nous contre nous donc
c'est pas bon davos est un coût qui
tient olivier tauzin d'ouvragés de
tranquille tranquille
donc là il peut pas sciemment par
exemple doubler les tours que je tourage
3 wii suivi de tours a h1n1 plan-là
karpov victoire 38 tours à agen
c'est vrai que ça s'est assez fort il ya
peut-être des combinaisons direct qui
vont mal je pense qu'une menace aussi
tout simplement donc cavaliers pros âge
cette gay pride pour prendre aux proches
c th projet si tu en prends g6 qui
attaquent la tour et après les charges
des tours il pourra rentrer sur la case
html peut revenir en fuite ou six mois
et ça n'a pas l'air de marcher
directement genre si si ça marche
directement puisque absence pourrait le
faisons par exemple le coup à cinq
cavaliers pranger qui perdent un temps
donc pour voir la menace des blancs ça
c'est une simulation totale
quel point cette non tabei prochain
juste après 7 tours prend pions proche
des six si on prend g6 tour prochain
tous reprochent au prochain tour à
schwyz courage cet échec pour acheter t
shirts et la pointe voilà d'accord donc
ça c'est la menace
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est fait avant
il ya comprend échecs et ses filles
ouais c puis l'a menacé d'un machin qui
est des machinistes et ça monte donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est imparable peut-être attention
menace imparable donc les noirs ont
décidé finalement de protéger le roi le
plus possible pour éviter donc
cette combinaison torah j'évite ange
entourage et 8 il prépare la fuite du
roi paref 8e 8
oui donc le roi noir qui qui veut donc
finalement quitté les droits et
finalement c'est la preuve que la
stratégie des blancs donc d'installer de
fragiliser la structure de pion à l'est
le roi était la bonne
balala on voit dans cette position que
c'est très probablement un énorme succès
puisqu'on a du mal à croire
quoi qu'en dise l'ordinateur qui n'est
pas de combinaison bien dans cette
position est d'ailleurs il y en a une et
ce qui est intéressant dans cette partie
c'est que les cours ont été joués par
les blancs peuvent très bien très
facilement être trouvée par part par un
joueur
oui et quand même arrive à à comment
dire à détruire donc la carapace donc de
l'ordinateur ce qui veut dire que si on
devait comment dire si on devait tirer
une conclusion en tant que programmeur
d'un logiciel il faudrait éliminer donc
cette défense est un viennent du
répertoire aux défenses contre g37
défense contre g3 est passé à autre
chose tout simplement attention c'est
peut-être l'humain qui a choisi aussi
l'ouverture c'est ça arrive fréquemment
on peut imposer à l'ordinateur une
ouverture donc la voie la torah j'ai
vite vous avez le temps de réfléchir la
position pendant que nous discutions
philosophiquement de la puissance
relative des ordinateurs est donc
maintenant il y a le gain immédiat donc
que jean luc a mentionné tout à l'heure
la combinaison qui tue cavaliers prend
h77 donc un coup de massue la menace
c'est à ce projet si ce nom d'un parti
ce matin mm x qui qui qui est assez fort
donc ici forcer tous reproches 7 pions
pranger six tours prochain tour proches
menaces thorax est qu'ils gagnent la
dame nostro rachète avec gain de dames
puisque la dame sera confiné croyais
huit tours achètent quand même pour
acheter
ça monte
attac la dame mon si la dame bouge ça va
aller très vite avec g7 tout simplement
par exemple un coup comme d'amd vite way
qui n'est pas une défense puisque là il
ya chez cet échec
j'ai cet échec est donc suroît plus d'un
matelas nadia matt ya un match très
simple puisque le suroît de sa dette ont
jeté des objets cinq ans et comme je
suis j'ai 6 mars suivi d'un
fléchissement de classe ça va très très
vite tout simplement tour h7
on ne peut pas bouger la dame il faut
jouer tour j'ai sept trophées 7,7
c'est joli cette position maintenant
plusieurs solutions
donc on voit que ce retour à schwyz ils
à tours j'ai vite ouais ça tiens ça a
l'air de tenir puisque songé cet échec
les dames confiant on a trois points gsm
donc ça ne marche pas d'âme h5 le coup
de l'évier touzanne tranquille
tranquille avec une menace avec l'idée
que si les noirs font de tout reproche
sept ont fait puis on prend h tête et
d'un mot prochaine coupe des dames au
prochain coup donc les noirs peuvent
rien faire et la menace c'est de jouer
damage 6 et mat qui cloue et ensuite
tour à ce rythme at oui exactement là
tranquille en fait c'est des gens ne
coupe pas facile à voir pour un
ordinateur
oui c'est un visage positif
c'est pas évident peut-être la seule
défense c'est peut-être de jouer fouet 8
faut vite c'est un coût possible
je pense pas que ça défendent évidemment
puisque ça a l'air cette pression a
l'air catastrophique on peut toujours
jouer de damages 6 mois louis latour
menace matt des matches 6 c'est vrai que
ça a l'air fort menace mat
la seule défense sekaggya système comme
dans la partie d'un lot de faits
similaires concours andrée le cavalier
good canary dame prend donc ici déjà les
blancs ont récupéré leurs pièces
2 il ya égalité matérielle donc ça c'est
normal
et ils ont toujours la tacc ils sont
toujours là tac beaucoup de possibilités
de conclure notamment le coût est de 5
c'est exactement similaire à la partie
donc on va se contenter de regarder la
partie qui après damage 5 donc il n'y a
pas eu faut vite qu'ils étaient un coût
possible
il est une fille prend b2 autant mourir
le ventre plein exactement puisque
maintenant en plus on menace de
perception c'est aujourd'hui comme au
moins inscrire inscrits au cas où les
blancs se trompent les normes vont
gagner la partie
damages 6 ça y est là c'est mathématique
manas matin un gain mathématiques manas
matt menace maître tura chute cavalière
six salles défense du cavaliere si seule
défense parce que surtout rage suite
lecavalier 6 reviendrait sur la case g8
exactement c'est une interception de ce
match du couloir
ce qui fait qu'on est obligé donc de
prendre ce cavalier
toujours couronnées cet ouvrage suit
exactement d'un problème si ce qui
libère donc qui libère la case de 7 pour
le roi qui offre une case de roy salaire
bien pour les noirs c'est ça l'art
d'aller pour la noire ça a l'air d'aller
pour les noirs mais là donc les blancs
ont toujours l'initiative et vont
exploiter donc vont exploiter le jeu sur
case noire en jouant tour à schwyz 3e
set et f5 f/4 5-5 très forts menacent
fujisan menace des sacs de billets de la
dame
mike kigen à damas je ne souhaite plus à
ces menaces de cloud la dame menace de
plus la dame et de la prendre
donc là n'y a pas 36 défense c'est très
simple on voit tout de suite que dame 5
perd rapidement d'un match fou j'ai cinq
échecs
ouais on aura des six forcé ff4
enfermement
qui de nouveau on peut aussi regarder
donc au lieu de dames se sent qu'on peut
regarder le ku'damm dégâts tard éclate
dès qu'ils perdraient assez simplement à
après il ya dieu six échecs qui arrivent
ici le meilleur qu à la date d'un match
4 en fait qui gagne aussi très vite
wade à mach 4 mai à la trêve avec un
matt probable d'un mach 4 7 assez fort
donc sur deux même si c'est très sain
qu'il y à fond j'ai cinq et ce roi
décide seul autre coup ya quatre ans
l'un des six faut être quatre ou cinq
et là on peut jouer la même si celui
d'amd huit dames est aussi celui de fo
prône simple oui non un nombre d'indécis
sud inde et vite c'est bien là le fils
d'un f3 c'est cette force et d'amd vite
md83 des six aux dames b 8 ha oui
maintenant on passe par des huit mois la
très jolie me sert aux seuls et dames
les arbitres mais là c'est superbe c'est
une très belle variante ouais on va la
revoir
bon ça c'est des variantes que
l'ordinateur quels très vite alors
maintenant jean-luc la sas et c'est là
que c'est important d'avoir l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur en quelques instants il va
dire matt way oui on va dire que
l'humain a fait son travail il la
trouvait donc les manoeuvres
stratégiques les plus importantes
le choix de l'ouverture et l'ordinateur
fait le reste quand on arrive dans la
position qui est gagnante pourquoi
perdre son temps à calculer les
variantes ce qui compte finalement dans
ce type de rencontre c'est d'avoir les
bonnes idées mais d'utiliser la machine
pour le calcul pour le reste exactement
d'un mach 4 donc la voir en 3d 6 x 4
échecs de 5 forcé et maintenant la
petite quadrille angulation la cadrature
du cercle des six aura des huit forcé
damas vite ils sont un des six daims
belgique ou un v8 est un petit matin en
fuite perdre c'est joli donc après 9,5
il n'y a plus de défenses donc peut-être
brand jour roi des six fois f4 et shake
shake
donc là il n'est pas question de jouer
ce soit ou 5 puisque sauf aux 5 fu g5
des jeunes c'est la partie mais sur cinq
il ya foule g5 au cinéma n'a jamais plus
heureux cette gaffe ou g5 bout quoi
qu'il arrive y aura foule et 55 fou j'ai
foulé 5
et là c'est terminé tout simplement et
oui jamais perdu oui donc l'aller les
noirs ont prises ont fait et ils vont
fêter un petit peu mais sans trouver lé
pouvoir défense ou et tour plonger 6
faut point m6 une dame de plus tôt
reprend à 6 tours prend donc ici on a
une tour de plus une tour de plus
bon attention à ces trois pions c'est
vrai qu'ils étaient déjà arrivés
jusqu'ici ce serait dangereux mais là
ils sont vraiment trop loin
donc pas de problème vous pas fou il
faut deux ans plus échanger des photos
reprend et là le problème c'est que ce
roi aux cinq qui a l'air de gagner le
fou et bien non il est tout à fait
contre attaque sur l'autre fou donc
après avoir s'être la partie a continué
c'est vrai que c'est une constante chez
ces parties du champion du monde elle
continue toujours jusqu'au bout en bout
rond un niveau de jeu énorme et les
joueurs n'abandonne pas donc oui nous on
y croit un méga jamais de gaza salah
disant que c'est on peut se tromper
aussi comme c'est pas un échiquier réel
on peut se tromper sur la souris qui ça
arrive
oui hier que leur slip voilà la souris
qui glisse voilà c'est ça et on se
trompe et on lâche la pièce au mauvais
endroit et on perd la partie
c'est peut-être aussi ainsi que la
plupart des joueurs ne sont pas des
professionnels puisque en général dans
ce type de position un professionnel
avant un professionnel a confiance donc
dans le jeu ton adversaire et abandonne
et là les joueurs donc qu'ils sont plus
plus là finalement pour le fun et pour
pour l'amusement tentent leur chance
jusqu'au bout
si on prend 1,6 je sais pas s'il est là
pour le fun roy prend m6 puis on prend
ça c'est les 5 donc la maintenance et un
gain technique c'est à dire que le roi
blanc va stopper les points noirs et les
deux pions blancs vont tout simplement
avancé à l'est roanne loire ne peut pas
à la fois empêché le pion des et le
plonger dans la dame dont la la on
empêche l'option d'avancé mais normal
maintenant plus qu'à pousser moyens on
peut jouer 3 enfin tout gagne on regarde
juste la conclusion d'olivier touzanne
un des quatre handicaps les 5 g 5
complètement impuissants les noirs dans
cet étang voilà ça c'est une tentative
de l'ordinateur d'un ordinateur pour ces
trois rendez-vous g600 et la vida avance
adam
donc voilà on va conclure quand même sur
sur ce débat alors jean-luc on assiste à
une compétition d chaque avancée
c'est à dire sommes plus ordinateur
c'est pratiquement certain
compte tenu du niveau de jeu des partis
du fait que les joueurs trouvent quand
même systématiquement les coûts cas pas
de gaffe les coûts complexe ya jamais de
gaffes
donc qu'est ce qui va faire la
différence entre donc entre tous ces
pseudos qui ne sont même pas forcément
des joueurs je crois que ça fait partie
donc des grands débats qui sont lancés
par cette compétition
c'est à dire que il me semble
actuellement que
qu' il n'est pas facile de dire si un
ordinateur seul peut peut vaincre
n'importe n'importe quelle équipe
c'est à dire quand je dis n'importe
quelle équipe c'est-à-dire homeplus
machine oui en plus machines dont
l'ordinateur le plus puissant
est-ce que tout seul peut battre donc un
homme plus une machine femme très
performante
ou est-ce qu'il faut l'intervention
humaine ça c'est la question que je me
pose actuellement et c'est pas vraiment
une vraie question c'est plutôt si un
ordinateur capable de battre n'importe
qui à quoi ça sert d'organiser des
compétitions sur internet oui ça peut
également une surtout si l'ordinateur
est commercialement commercialisés c'est
à celui qui manipule qui manie mieux le
mieux l'ordinateur c'est vrai mais le
problème c'est que tant qu'on n'aura pas
répondu à ma question
on ne pourra pas répondre à une autre
question c'est que tant qu'un humain
aura aura la halle conduire aura la
possibilité de battre avec une machine
de battre une machine seul
oui on pourra organiser ce genre de
compétition la compétition aura un sens
oui avait d'un côté c'est pas forcément
le meilleur joueur qui sera capable de
faire peut-être le la meilleure salle
bien mal meilleurs joueurs évidemment ça
le jour le mieux préparé à ce type de
rencontre tout à fait mais le fait est
que c'est quand même des qualifications
pour un tournoi où là il y aura plus
d'ordinateurs après c'est à dire qu'ils
vont devoir jouer face à samsung
non c'est pas puisqu'il ya quelques
années il ya eu 1
en allemagne je crois un joueur qui
avait joué en open oui il y avait une
oreillette et il savait pas du tout joué
aux échecs
on s'est douté qu'il avait l'ordinateur
parce que il faisait de très belles
parties il arrive avec de battre des
grands maîtres etc puis des fois ils
réfléchissaient une heure sur un coût
qui est évident il ne jouait pas parce
qu'en fait tu savais même pas jouer aux
échecs et il joue et que les coups qu'on
lui donne l ordinateur par le café mais
en fait il avait été repéré le jour où
il a abattu un très fort grand maître et
l'autre fois au grand maître abandonne à
lui dit évidemment il ya vatan vite bon
alors que évidemment la position très
compliqué personne sur terre ne pouvait
annoncer maintenant huit décemment est
donc là on a dit bon écoute nous c'est
pas possible
moi je vais car il est de toute façon
c'est pas très grave il ya eu huit
places qualificatives par cette
compétition et je suis sûr que les
joueurs qui est qu'ils n'ont pas le
niveau se font éliminer probablement au
premier tour mais on peut tout à fait
envisager peut-être que ce genre de
qualification puisse servir un
championnat du monde d'échecs avancé
justement ouais enfin pas d'ailleurs oui
ça ne pourrait être ça pourra pas de ça
pour être bien que ni un spectacle mais
il a de jouer tout à fait mais on peut
très bien jouer aux échecs en est conçu
avec la cia l'ordinateur mais j'avais
organisé d'ailleurs le match entre
kasparov et les grandes écoles les
sélections pour ce qui est de jouer en
consultation en équipe donc c'est de son
ordinateur sans ordinateur mais
effectivement le nom mais là ça aurait
été dur quand même pourquoi ne pas dire
pour kasparov effectivement même à
l'époque l'une ordinateur était quand
même assez fort mais
c'est intéressant le jeu par équipe où
et pourquoi pas le vrai c'est du vrai je
parie qu'ils se font avec effectivement
on est à plusieurs réfléchira même pas
la même partie actualité toujours avec
le match etienne bacrot contre émile
sitôt fini donc match au sommet match
annuel en maintenant c'est devenu une
tradition stéphane depuis que nous
avions été voir maintenu les maquereaux
un papou wide shut off line toujours on
avait été donc filmé le match avec bbs
skin white tout à fait il avait déjà
joué contre corps chaud il avait déjà
joué contre les vannes aronian qui est
maintenant un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde short autres shorts l'internaute
rue binaire il a toute une liste
d'adversaires à son palmarès est là il
s'attaque aux champions d'europe
oui alors à noter quand même que
faites-vous chez lui et surtout ses
matchs il a eu beaucoup de mal il a en
fait il a perdu contre courant il a
perdu contre short
oui donc il y avait c'était des joueurs
quand même un cran au-dessus à l'époque
maintenant il joue ministre ski qui
chante en europe qui est donc très très
fort et par contre cette fois on sent
qu'il a la possibilité de gagner ils ont
même plus loin où ils ont du mal à 150
chacun sait ça donc ils ont des très
fortes classement elo donc le match est
normalement très équilibré jean luc est
ce que tu as suivi un peu ton camarade
de club med pas vraiment d'accord avec
l'analyse de stéphane c'est que milito
si si les champions d'europe c'est que
il est probablement actuellement plus en
forme que des cordes chinois ou autres
joueurs ah oui je dis que cette cette
année j'ai pour la première fois il a le
niveau pour battre un joueur de cette
classe de cette classe là ben non je
pense que oui des niveaux mais son
adversaire est plus fort que ses
adversaires habituels puisque c'est leur
disant qu'ils étaient l'un progresser
c'est ce que je veux dire c'est qu'elle
sait qu etienne a considérablement
progressé que et que
et que mémé que son adversaire est plus
fort que d'habitude
il est plus vigilant plus fort que son
camping ou des leafs qui oui enfin
certainement pas plus fort que short ou
qui quand même et d'un calibre vraiment
impressionnant actuellement les
résultats de choc ne sont pas excellents
je pense que je sors que j'inclus n'est
pas en très grande forme puisqu'il avait
perdu contre igor au chocolat du monde
par exemple moyennement bref peu importe
en tout cas suite au ski c'est un
adversaire assez remarquable et le score
après trois rondes avantage etienne qui
mène 2 1
il a gagné une partie et fait deux nuls
donc vous pouvez consulter les partis
sur le site www.eurostar.com il ya
toutes les parties à télécharger et vous
verrez une deuxième partie totalement
stupéfiante vraiment incroyable alors je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu en tout
cas elle est délirante oui mais elle
s'arrête alors que les kelly alors
qu'elle commence où elle commençait sa
position extrêmement compliqué s'arrête
abruptement donc être un peu contre le
spectacle match nul sur la deuxième
partie alors que quand ça c'est la
position ça s'arrête
il ya une grande dynamique dans le jeu
qu'on ne peut pas dire le contraire
les noirs ont monté une grande demande
paraît extrêmement compliqué donc
deuxième partie de ce match à
télécharger sur le site d'europe échec
par exemple dernière dernière chose
maintenant on va peut-être aborder les
tournois à venir donc là nous avons
notre spécialiste en tournoi puisqu'il
s'agit d'un joueur très actifs dans l'ue
chabanon qui a étudié pour vous tous les
tournois à venir donc pour ce mois
d'octobre novembre ces deux mois pouvait
donc beaucoup de tournois la toussaint
une actualité très chargée beaucoup de
tournois dans toute la france donc
évidemment je pense qu'on peut pas ne
pas parler en premier jean-luc du
tournoi de bastia ont quand même
phénoménal ce ne doit pas passer donc à
côté du tournoi de bastia donc un
tournoi qui a six cent mille francs de
prix je crois 600 litres en dotation
totale et ou avec une affiche
exceptionnelle puisque je crois qu'il y
aura donc mais y'aura à londres l'indien
wichmann adonnent à nantes qui a gagné
l'an dernier mais qui va jouer bien
réussir offre plus de nombreux grands
peine de mort aux emiratis simplement
les deux finalistes du championnat du
monde
l'an dernier il y en a tant donné sauf
kasparov trawick a priori way qui eux on
a du mal à les attraper
en tout cas ce tournoi de bastia va être
tout à fait exceptionnel ça se passe sur
trois jours ou quatre ça se passe oui
donc sur sur trois jours donc pour les
grands maîtres et la compétition donc
avec les tournois annexes dure quatre
jours donc un clin d'oeil était joué là
bas tu peux peut-être nous décrire un
peu le cadre oui donc on avait déjà été
filmée bastia donc est un tournoi qui
qui est très bien organisé donc dans une
très belle salle et c'est une ville très
très sympa c'est très sympa de soissons
d'aller jouer en corse
donc avis corse merci de nous accueillir
en tout cas on essaiera d'aller nombreux
vous voir on se rappelle stéphane du
match etienne bacrot j'ai dit paul bien
évidemment les messieurs etienne bacrot
donc toujours dans ces histoires de
match c'était le premier directeur
premier direct de diagonale sinistre et
même premier direct de marché chez que
lui sur internet de l'histoire des
échecs
enfin en vidéo et en vidéo sur la vidéo
tout à fait voilà donc il ya ce tournoi
là et maintenant il y en a aussi
d'autres en france alors ça si vous avez
envie de jouer un tournoi la toussaint
voilà des tournois qu'il y aura peu près
une semaine je crois qu'on va faire un
petit tour de france donc si vous êtes
dans le nord de la france vous pouvez
aller jouer au touquet par exemple alors
le touquet est extrêmement sympathique
tournoi vraiment très bien organisés
dans une énorme salle tout en pierres
massives et ses frais une station
balnéaire trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
charme et donc un très sympathique et
vous pourrez essayer au passage la soupe
de poissons du restaurant chez paiera il
faut pas faire de pub enfin en tout cas
elle est vraiment délicieuse donc l esi
n'ayez pas peur elle donnerait aux
câpres aussi enfin allez y le touquet
c'est vraiment très bien ce qui vous
attend demain il y aura un tournoi donc
si vous habitez en touraine il ya un
tour à tour du tournoi très très fort
donc
le twin towers très dur 3 4 jo est
exactement
je crois qu'il vient ton à sautron aussi
dans la région nantaise alors il paraît
qu'il est extrêmement relevé ce tournoi
puisque à ce jour il y aurait déjà plus
de 30 titres inscrits donc si vous êtes
fan de joueurs titrés si vous avez envie
d'en rencontrer bien aller à sautron
c'est là où il y aura probablement le
plus beau palmarès après basta
évidemment et si vous aimez le soleil et
ben je vous conseille soit le l'open de
toulon dont les trésoreries qui va être
très très fort qui se joue au palais
neptune donc bon le charme de la côte
d'azur est également le tournoi de
menton donc le tome 1 de menton que
auxquelles je vais participer donc là on
aura l'occasion de voir le joueur le
plus bronzé du circuit et voilà donc il
y aura aussi mon ami anglais tony kosten
qui va jouer le grand maître
international et d'autres grands matches
ce sera aussi un tournoi très
sympathique dans une ville dans une
ville qui a beaucoup de charme
donc elles ont pour résumer on va
conseiller donc par région allez dans
votre région
ça c'est le premier choix deuxième chose
si vous voulez voir des très très fort
grand maître des très bons joueurs
allaient à bastia et ensuite si vous
voulez vous amuser manger de la bonne
soupe de poisson vous allez au touquet
pour avoir toutes les informations sur
les tendances vous allez sur le site
fédéral www.fff.fr et là vous aurez les
informations sur tous les tournois avec
les téléphones des organisateurs les
dates les cadences bref tout pour passer
des très bonnes vacances de la toussaint
dans le milieu des échecs donc on va
arrêter là cette émission ces femmes
elles rendez vous la semaine prochaine
si dieu le veut
oui je pensais comme ça qu'on dit voilà
jean-luc merci d'avoir participé à cette
édition merci j'espère que
quelle aventure va continuer sinon bah
j'ai dit bientôt tous les
téléspectateurs et est à toi et moi et
elle s'est faite donc nous souhaitons
bonne chance en tout cas tous nos
français engagé sur ce championnat du
monde qualificative par internet et on
vous dit rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle et peut être
dernière émission de diagonale merci
nous avons reçues